[Music]
tesla on thursday released a redesigned
version of its model s
luxury sedan dubbed the model s plaid
the vehicle is priced starting around
130 thousand dollars
capable of going zero to 60 miles per
hour
in less than two seconds you know why
make this really fast car
that's crazy fast and everything and i
think there there is
something that's quite important um to
the future of sustainable energy which
is
that uh we got to show that an electric
car
is the best car hands down
you know model s plaid has a redesigned
interior
that features three display screens the
vehicle has some unusual characteristics
including a yoke shaped steering wheel
it really feels like okay we're in 2021
great
the idea behind redesigns such as this
one typically is to drum
up renewed customer interest automakers
have
long done this so let's deliver some
cars
all right and this is just another sign
that tesla
in some ways has transformed from a
startup to an established manufacturer
chief executive elon musk said he
thought the model s plaid would be in
customer hands in february
but found the overhaul to be more
difficult than expected because of
issues such as ensuring the battery and
the revamped model is safe
the delay has meant that tesla has
largely missed out on what's been a
booming market for luxury vehicles in
the first months of this year
tesla is facing increasing amounts of
competition from startups and legacy
automakers alike
that are pouring money into developing
their own electric models
the hope for tesla is that this refresh
spurs renewed interest in one of its
classics